Kim jong-un well he needs a summit to
happen more than the u.s. here with
reaction author of the upcoming book the
briefing former White House press
secretary Sean Spicer is with us and
former White House press secretary Fox
News contributor Ari Fleischer it's it's
a sad position for Democrats to be in
all these 14 record states on a low
unemployment all these different
demographics on low unemployment records
you know the president North Korea is a
great thing for them to be happy he has
to fail well that's all true but Sean I
have a surprising conclusion about how
bad it is with the press it's actually
good for Republicans because the press
is so separating itself from the
American people particularly in the
battleground states that the Democrats
read their good favorable press clips
they read the vehement anti vitriolic
Trump clips and they believe them and
the more they believe the good press
they're getting the more they separate
themselves from the voters the press has
separated themselves from the American
people so you have a slice left that
believes the press you might be the last
press secretary that ever had a chance
our friend Sean Spicer who did it Sean I
don't know how you did that job they
can't pay anybody enough for that job
and Sarah Huckabee is amazing she has
the patience of Job I could not do the
job you two have done the wounds are
finally starting to heal I would agree
with can I can I just say something in
North Korea though look the funny part
is all those clips forget what the
president said at the beginning which is
if we get a deal great I might walk out
he laid the predicate for this a long
time ago and everybody's forgetting how
he approached this to begin with that's
the important thing the president has
made very clear that he's willing to
meet with him but he's willing to walk
away from the table that's what all of
these people in their reports have
forgotten and you're absolutely right
he's gotten Kim jong-un to give three
American hostages back he's gotten them
to start talking about denuclearizing
the Korean Peninsula
unemployment's at a record-low so many
millions of Americans are benefiting and
they are doing whatever they can to
figure out what negative news to cover
because at the end of the day what's so
fascinating is most Americans are saying
you know what this president's keeping
his promises he's getting things done
and
America's a better country before it so
I know that for a lot of folks in the
press corps they're trying to figure out
where else can I find what can I can I
go after him on but at the end of the
day are he's right they continue to show
how wildly out of touch they are with
the American people because the
president is getting results both
domestically and foreign policy-wise
he's keeping the country safe he's
developing jobs he's creating a robust
second shot bring it back to North Korea
for a second if Trump decides he's not
gonna go the press is gonna blame Donald
Trump if Kim Jong woman decides he's not
gonna go the press is gonna blame Donald
Trump they will not blame the communist
totalitarian dictator they'll blame
Donald Trump in the DMZ what about no
rockets fired over Japan they covered
the hostages but it was a one-day story
but this is again Shawn my point about
how the press is separating itself from
the people that they rely on depend on
to buy their papers and news Jill
Abramson the former executive editor of
The New York Times said that every time
Trump calls on fake news she hears the
ching of the cash register as more
people subscribe online that's the curse
of the new york times because the people
are subscribing online are so
oppositional to donald rotting the
failure to deliver the opposition it's
becoming the voice of the opposition
newspapers the media cannot be
oppositional they have to be factual
that's what's gotten lost how do you
explain how horrible CNN by the way I
want residuals from CNN and MSNBC
because they run me all the time it's so
unfair they need to pay me sucker needs
to pay me but in all seriousness they're
not doing well with this when do they if
I was if I was watching a president give
a speech and they were chanting Fox News
sucks I'd be that might take it
seriously after a while you know the
funny thing on my end is is during the
campaign season I was very public I gave
a lot of credit to CNN in terms of how
they covered the campaign how they ran
their debates and then suddenly on
January 11th when Jim Jim Acosta decided
to become a carnival barker they decided
to change their entire model and realize
that their model was now to try to
follow MSNBC and become the other
resistance and and I think it's sad
because they've made it personal and
their ratings are suffering because of
it
and I think that they've gotta know
every one of these hosts goes on air and
tries to outdo them Matthews is become
the model form I'm the problems the
presses job is not to be the resistance
but they enjoy that role that and they
relish it and it's they always do it to
Republicans and they particularly do it
to Trump and it's gonna get worse even
when Trump's gone thank you both